Traduttore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Revisore: Silvia Forato
Buon giorno, ciao a tutti.
Sì, posizione e rotta.
Questo, anche questo, soprattutto questo
serve quando uno va per mare.
Sì, sono un oceanografo,
meglio, oceanologo,
se vogliamo essere un po' più precisi,
a me piace di più.
Mi occupo soprattutto di oceano e clima.
Oceano, non oceani,
perché in realtà di oceano
ce n'è uno solo.
L'oceano è il mio campo di studio,
ma anche, per me,
tutto sommato un amico.
E gli amici, si sa, a volte aiutano,
a volte vanno aiutati,
sempre però sarebbe meglio ascoltarli.
Girando il mondo,
seppur colpito dal mal di mare,
qualche storia l'ho sentita
e oggi vorrei proporvene due,
perché in fondo, vedete,
anche in questa regione
che vedete nella figura,
che noi chiamiamo di solito
indistintamente Polinesia,
già 4.000 anni fa le persone
che solcavano i suoi mari
con queste canoe a bilanciere,
avevano lo stesso problema
dell'uomo moderno:
conoscere la propria posizione.
È importante farlo
se vivi in un contesto
come quello delle isole Marshall,
dove 34 atolli buttati così, a caso quasi,
tra le Hawaii e l'Australia,
si staccano dal livello medio del mare
per trenta centimetri solo in altezza.
Perché appena sei al largo a pescare,
un po' d'onda dalla tua canoa
non ti fa vedere più nulla.
E quindi la tua posizione
è un problema importante,
perché ti serve tornare a casa.
Bene, voi direte: "Questo è un problema
che tanti hanno avuto,
le stelle il sole, qualche trucchetto
per orientarsi in mare
l'uomo l'ha sempre usato."
Giusto.
I marshallesi no.
L'unico popolo che ha usato
e usa ancora
le onde come indicatore naturale
della propria posizione.
E lo fanno, lo facevano,
e chi è ancora capace lo fa,
usando uno strumento come questo:
bastoncini di navigazione
delle isole Marshall.
Una serie di legnetti di cocco ricurvi,
piegati in un modo artigianale,
con all'intersezione delle conchiglie.
Questo racchiude l'informazione
di generazioni di abitanti delle Marshall
che hanno tradotto l'andamento
delle onde di Swell,
quelle onde distanti,
generate da un vento distante,
che poi arrivano a frangere però
vicino alla tua costa.
Vi sarete chiesti ogni tanto,
"Perché c'è onda qui
che non c'è vento?"
Ecco, quell'onda è partita
da distante e sta arrivando,
quella è l'onda lunga, l'onda di Swell.
Il marshallese sulla sua canoa torna
muovendo le dita su questa sorta di abaco,
perché riconosce l'altezza dell'onda
che colpisce la sua canoa e la frequenza.
Avendo memorizzato da generazioni
nei propri canali semicircolari
quello che è l'andamento dell'onda,
muove le dita,
riconosce all'incrocio... cosa?
La posizione del proprio atollo,
perché ognuna di queste isolette
respinge in un modo unico,
con una musica unica e particolare,
l'onda lunga che la colpisce.
Meglio di un GPS.
Sto disteso, avverto quello che avviene,
sento cosa accade intorno a me,
e da questo capisco dove sono.
Conosco la mia posizione
perché so leggere l'informazione del mare.
Cambiamo per un attimo noi
posizione questa volta,
e ci portiamo sulla costa sud-orientale
dell'isola di Oahu, Hawaii.
Mattina presto,
l'oceano non ha ancora
lasciato salire il sole,
lo trattiene all'alba,
eppure siamo già in tanti di fronte
alla scogliera di Diamond Head.
Ognuno che guarda l'orizzonte,
convinto di saper trovare
quella increspatura sul rift,
sulla barriera,
che ti consente di smettere di pagaiare,
di salire sulla tavola
e cavalcare un'onda.
Le stesse onde che arrivavano
dai nostri amici delle Marshall
arrivano alle Hawaii.
Sempre un'onda distante,
un'oda di Swell,
che va a frangere sulla barriera.
Cavalchi quest'onda,
una gioia, per chi fa surf,
impagabile, è vero,
effimera ma impagabile.
E mentre l'onda ti si srotola
sotto la tavola,
non sai bene quanto grato
tu dovresti essere
alla curiosità di Walter Heinrich Munk,
nato a Vienna nel 1917
e tre settimane fa
festeggiato per i 101 anni,
uno dei padri dell'oceanografia moderna.
Quando Munk cominciò ad occuparsi
delle onde lunghe,
aveva da poco lasciato
un lavoro in banca a New York,
dove era stato spedito
nel 1932 dalla famiglia,
perché in Austria amava sciare
e poco studiare,
a dire il vero,
e perché aveva un nonno banchiere,
vabbe', questo aiuta.
Però Walter non amava molto
il lavoro di banca,
e i suoi leones erano altri.
Non si trovava bene lì,
amava l'onda delle coste californiane.
E cominciò da lì a studiare
proprio in un periodo in cui
un'altra onda, ben più grave,
ben più cupa,
colpiva l'Europa proprio partendo
dalla sua Austria.
Entrò in contatto con il mondo
della marina militare americana
proprio per studiare la possbilità
di effettuare degli sbarchi
in condizioni di onda
nel mar Mediterraneo o nel Mare del Nord.
Fino a quel momento
le barche utilizzate per lo sbarco
erano questa sorta
di grossi mattoncini LEGO,
che avrete probabilmente visto
in tanti filmati del D-day.
E queste barche con un'onda solo di
un metro e mezzo d'altezza significativa
non riuscivano però ad operare lo sbarco.
Era però considerato da tutti una sorta
di inevitabile pena, un problema,
in fondo una variabile in più
in quella che era
una guerra sporca e lontana.
No, per Munk no.
Lui cominciò a studiare,
questa è una riproduzione
di una delle sue prime carte,
la velocità del vento,
che vedete nell'asse di sinistra,
e la lunghezza per
la quale il vento può soffiare,
e la vedete nell'asse x, in basso.
Più un vento è forte
e più ha a disposizione
un terreno libero su cui soffiare,
bene, Walter ricavò a mano,
perché all'epoca i conti
si facevano a mano,
era inutile affidarsi
ai primissimi calcolatori,
a matita,
l'altezza dell'onda che può derivare,
crescente ovviamente,
più è intenso il vento
e più è lunga la distanza,
e anche la direzione dell'onda
che doveva avere.
Quindi,
lo fece così bene che queste tabelline
convinsero il presidente Eisenover
a spostare lo sbarco del D-day
dal 5 giugno al 6 giugno del '44,
proprio per evitare delle onde
che avrebbero impedito lo sbarco
da parte di quelle barche
fatte a forma di mattoncino LEGO.
Il resto è storia per noi,
però rimane ancora quest'altra
geniale intuizione.
Prevedo oggi cosa accadrà domani,
nel caso di Munk prevedo
il vento di domani,
e con il vento di domani
io ti posso fissare una rotta
perché prevedo l'onda di domani.
Anche questo geniale.
E queste sono le due storie,
posizione e rotta,
sulle quali adesso ragioniamo insieme.
L'uomo moderno, l'uomo contemporaneo,
noi che abbiamo oramai
raggiunto e superato
alcuni limiti planetari, globali,
non solo per quanto riguarda
gli effetti del cambiamento climatico,
ma anche per la perdita di biodiversità,
per l'uso dei terreni,
per lo sfasamento dei cicli biogeochimici,
l'uomo contemporaneo
riesce a fissare una posizione
e ad avere una rotta?
Bene, in realtà l'abbiamo
scoperto anche oggi,
le cose stanno cambiando
molto più velocemente
di quanto pensassimo qualche anno fa.
E questa non è una situazione che ci mette
molto a nostro agio,
Accade per le onde?
Sì, accade per le onde,
che sono, in alcuni casi, non ripetibili,
non più ripetibili come lo sono state
per gli abitanti delle isole Marshall,
cambiano la loro frequenza,
quindi non sono più memorizzabili,
ma accade anche
per la frequenza dei venti,
per le precipitazioni, per i ghiacci,
per il clima di intere regioni,
e questo sta avvenendo
in modo molto veloce.
Certo, rispetto agli abitanti
delle Marshall,
possiamo misurare
una grandissima quantità di dati.
Abbiamo satelliti, sensori in mare,
sensori in atmosfera,
ma tutta questa informazione
non la riusciamo più a leggere,
non riusciamo più a leggere
tutta questa posta che ci arriva
e la nostra posizione cambia di continuo.
Ogni giorno fissiamo il valore massimo
di anidride carbonica in concetrazione
che abbiamo mai registrato negli ultimi
800 mila anni nell'atmosfera,
dei dieci anni più caldi
mai registrati finora al mondo,
otto si sono verificati dopo l'anno 2000,
perdiamo una concentrazione
di ghiaccio tale dal Polo Nord
che possiamo parlare di una massa
che viene fusa ogni giorno
pari a 3.000 volte il peso del Colosseo.
Ogni giorno viene fuso e va
come acqua dolce nell'Oceano Atlantico.
Tutto questo sta generando
un mondo in parte diverso,
uno degli effetti è l'innalzamento
del livello del mare
con il quale dovremo convivere
e che sta già adesso dandoci
segnali concreti
per disporre una vita sulle aree costiere
totalmente diversa
da quella che facevamo.
Nello stesso tempo non riusciamo
però nemmeno a tracciare una rotta
perché la rotta per il futuro
è influenzata soprattutto,
in prima istanza, dallo stile di sviluppo
che noi stessi dovremmo darci.
E anche questo ci mette in difficoltà.
Quindi, senza una posizione precisa
e senza una rotta,
non riusciamo in questo momento nemmeno
a fissare le priorità che dovremmo avere.
Le priorità dicevo.
Certo viviamo in un mondo complesso
dove piccole variazioni
possono verificarsi come conseguenza
in una grande differenza di rotta.
Parto da una situazione
leggermente diversa,
arrivo a una destinazione
totalmente diversa invece.
È successo con l'atmosfera.
In poco più di un secolo
abbiamo aumentato il livello
di anidride carbonica nell'atmofesra,
l'abbiamo portato dallo 0,2 permille
allo 0,4 permille.
Poca cosa, pensavamo,
è questione di gas rari,
invece è sufficiente per creare
un modo di un grado più caldo,
non solo nell'atmosfera,
ma anche nel mare.
E quindi questa cosa ci sta portando
verso un'altra situazione,
verso un altro leones.
Cosa possiamo fare
quindi in questo momento?
Cosa possiamo fare,
cosa possiamo imparare da queste storie
di fronte a un oceano che cambia?
Riusciamo a dare
un peso importante all'oceano?
Sappiamo, per esempio,
che l'oceano produce
il 50 percento dell'ossigeno
che respiriamo?
Sappiamo che incorpora il 30 percento
dell'anidride carbonica che emettiamo?
Sappiamo che proprio all'oceano dobbiamo
la stabilità del clima del pianeta?
Non credo.
Sappiamo che un Mediterraneo
più caldo di quasi due gradi
rispetto alla media degli ultimi 50 anni
è stato il principale responsabile
di quei venti così intensi
che hanno fatto strage
di milioni di alberi sulle Dolomiti?
No, perché di queste cose
non si parla abbastanza.
Cosa possiamo fare allora?
Io, dal punto di vista della scienza,
posso dire che cerco di lavorare
per una scienza
più interconnessa possibile,
dove fisica, matematica,
chimica, biologia si parlino insieme,
ma che includano anche le scienze sociali,
l'economia, la filosofia.
Come comunicatore,
posso aggiungere che la scienza dovrebbe
essere comunicata in tanti modi, efficaci,
non solo all'interno dello steccato
di uno scienziato,
ma anche in contesti,
per esempio, come questo.
Perché premo su questi due argomenti?
Perché abbiamo fretta,
dobbiamo velocemente
diventare consapevoli,
responsabili di quello che accade.
La stessa consapevolezza, in fondo,
che avevano proprio i pescatori
delle isole Marshall.
E quindi direi che, nel nostro dubbio,
nella possibilità o nell'impossibilità,
in questo momento,
di tracciare una rotta,
cosa possiamo fare?
Possiamo, forse, cercare di combinare
i due approcci che ho descritto.
Da una parte, le tabelline di Munk,
la scienza, la comprensione
delle dinamiche dell'atmosfera, del mare,
fatta con rigore, con metodo scientifico.
Dall'altra, i bastoncini,
la capacità di qualcuno di ascoltare
l'amico che non sta bene,
di ascoltarlo come facevano gli abitanti
delle isole Marshall.
Mettendo insieme queste due cose,
forse riusciamo a tracciare
una rotta per il futuro,
perché vedete,
gli abitanti delle isole Marshall
andavano a mare dopo che avevano imparato
ad utilizzare i loro bastoncini.
Prima studiavano, imparavano,
e poi utilizzavano.
Da questo dipendeva la loro sopravvivenza,
la capacità di tornare a casa,
di evitare un uragano
e di tornare alla capanna.
Con questa modalità evitavano di far male
a loro stessi e agli altri.
Forse questo potremmo cercare
di farlo anche noi.
Studiamo adesso, informiamoci,
approfondiamo gli argomenti,
diamo il peso che merita
al ruolo del nostro oceano,
che è il migliore alleato nel constrato
dei cambiamenti climatici.
Facciamolo subito,
per evitare di farci troppo male.
Aiuteremo senz'altro
il nostro amico oceano,
ma soprattutto consentiremo a lui
di continuare ad aiutare noi.
Grazie,
(Applausi)